- All right, oh, well, welcome, everyone.
My name's Tony Leiserowitz.
I'm a faculty member
over at the Yale School of the Environment
where I direct the Yale Program
on Climate Change Communication.
Here we're gonna be hearing
about this particular talk,
called Navigating the Future:
Harnessing Data-Driven
Insights on Climate Mobility
to Build a Common Agenda.
Very pleased to welcome to Yale,
two friends of mine who
I was just with last week
at Climate Week in New York,
doing a really big and exciting
and really important effort
to look at climate migration,
climate force displacement of peoples,
and how do we begin to think
proactively about managing
what is likely to be many
millions of people being forced
to move either temporarily or permanently.
So unfortunately the reality
of climate change is all too evident
over certainly this past summer
with all time record global temperatures.
But this has been happening
now for many, many years
for those that have been paying attention
and it's only getting more intense.
So this is an incredibly
time appropriate conversation
to be having and I'm just super excited
to welcome both of them
to Yale to help brief us
about some of the work they've been doing.
Here they're gonna unpack the
efforts of the Global Center
for Climate Mobility,
which they have spearheaded
to further climate mobility
knowledge and solutions.
They will underscore the
importance of data, modeling
and stakeholder engagement
to support proactive adaption strategies
for communities confronting
the climate crisis.
And so they're really gonna be presenting
this larger approach
of the GCCM "Anticipate, Plan & Transform"
and discuss the findings
and recommendations
of their Africa Climate
Mobility Initiative,
which is where they've started,
as well as ongoing work
to expand this in Latin
America and the Caribbean.
So I'll let them describe
the project in more detail,
but let me quickly introduce them.
David Lönnberg serves as
the Senior Advisor for Youth
and Outreach at the Global
Center for Climate Mobility
where he supports the Africa
Climate Mobility Initiative,
the Greater Caribbean
Climate Mobility Initiative
and the Rising Nations Initiative,
so you can see this is now very popular,
as well as the development
of the GCCM Solutions Lab.
He previously worked at NGO shift7
and the UN Non-Governmental
Liaison Service.
He also served as an advisor
to the Federal Foreign Office of Germany
and a consultant to the
UNICEF's Office of Innovation.
He holds a Master's in
International Affairs
from Columbia University
School of International
and Public Affairs and Sarah
Rosengaertner currently serves
as the Lead for Knowledge and Practice
of the Global Center for Climate Mobility,
where she oversees the efforts
of the Africa Climate Mobility Initiative
and the Greater Caribbean
Climate Mobility Initiative,
as well as the development of
GCCM's Global Knowledge Hub
with the Columbia
University Climate School.
She's a fellow at the Zolberg
Institute for Migration
and Mobility at the new
school and an adjunct lecturer
at Columbia University
School of International
and Public Affairs.
She previously held advisory
roles with several foundations,
universities and the UN
Secretary General on migration,
Peter Sutherland, focusing
on improving cooperation
on and the governance of
international migration.
She holds degrees in political science
from the Freie Universität in Berlin
and Sciences Po in Paris.
So with that, please join me
in welcoming both to Yale.
(crowd claps)
- Thanks, Tony.
Thanks, Teresa.
Thanks to everybody for
coming, everybody in the room,
everybody online, very excited to be here.
Thanks to MacMillan Center for hosting us.
I'm David and.
- [Sarah] I'm Sarah, thank you.
- [Tony] And, yeah, should we hit it off?
- [Sarah] Yeah.
- See if we can get to work.
So this is when what we're
gonna talk about today.
So we'll thought we'll do a
little bit of introduction
of who we are and the Global
Center for Climate Mobility,
GCCM, so if you're here at
GCCM, we come from the UN,
we use a lot of acronyms,
sorry, in advance.
That's how it's gonna be.
So I'm also gonna talk about
the regional accountability initiatives
and how sort of the
overall model is set up
of how we're working.
And then Sarah will go into more depth
and talk about the African
Climate Mobility Initiative.
Also refer to as ACMI, so if
somebody hear ACMI, that's it.
And then we have
the Greater Caribbean Climate
Mobility Initiative, GCCMI
to make it even harder.
Yeah, sorry, I was gonna
talk about that as well.
And then we'll have Q&A at the end.
If there are any burning
questions, throw up a hand,
we're easygoing, we'll get
to it and we can say, "Oh,
we'll come back to that" or
"We'll take it right away."
So we'll try to make this as interactive
and fun as possible.
You're very smart people here,
so I'm sure you'll have a lot of questions
and don't hold me in too
long so you forget them.
So looking at our goals,
as for our organization,
we have three things
that we try to mention.
It's anticipate, plan and transform.
So the anticipatory part is to
focus on all the early action
and being out early and
to be able to understand
what is going to happen
when it comes to climate-forced
migration and displacement,
also to refer to as climate mobility.
Then based on that information
that we get through the
knowledge work that we do,
we then try to convene policy
makers and stakeholders
in different convenings
to plan for what's ahead.
With that information and
with those coalitions,
then looking at how we
can guide adaptation work
and also work with the development
planning and investments
to address this in
climate mobility hotspots.
We'll come back to this notion of hotspots
and what that means, but that's something
that you'll hear quite a
lot in this presentation.
So how do we do this
when we're trying to address these goals?
We build knowledge, we advance policy
and we accelerate diplomacy
and enable practice.
Big words, but we try to live up to them.
We try to do various things within them.
Sarah, as you heard in
the interaction from Tony,
is leading our knowledge
work that really focus
on how the frontline communities
are gonna be affected
during the climate crisis
and what that's gonna do for mobility.
Based on that information,
we're then trying to advance coalitions
when it comes to policy to
take action, achieve justice,
and also then advance in
these different fields
that you see about outlined
peace building development,
et cetera in the policy area.
How this is done as well is
through accelerating diplomacy.
We come from the UN after all
and we work in that space.
So we have something to do with diplomacy.
This is a picture from last week.
Actually, both these
pictures are from last week,
but that's John Kerry
and this the president
of the UN general assembly
at ourC-level rise summit
that we had last first day.
So see how can we foster narratives
and advance climate mobility
in the international diplomatic space?
And also back to Sarah,
when it comes to practice,
how can we foster community
of practice around the world
that works on these topics?
We'll come back to this a bit more as well
when we look at the different initiatives
and what we do in the different regions.
So looking at the regional
models that we are using
for these different initiatives.
So we're working towards
people-centered climate action.
We can talk about mitigation,
we can talk about different
things that we need to do
because to tackle the climate crisis,
but we are also trying to bring back
the people into this
discussion and that's central
when you talk about
mobility and migration.
So it is a joint undertaking
and that's something we say,
we're UN, this and that,
but we also work with the World Bank
and regional organizations.
It's always anchor regional,
regional organization in Africa.
The African Union in the Great
Caribbean is the Association
of Caribbean States.
So tying back into these
things that we discussed
in the previous slides on the approach,
we are purchasing an
evidence-based approach.
We're also trying to
generate political momentum
through this coalition
building and agendas.
And then that hopefully leads to action
that is people-centered and
takes people into account
when we're trying to
tackle the climate crisis
and when we try to address
migration across these regions.
And I should say that
it, we work across these,
you see these different
terms here, climate action,
migration displacement and
sustainable development.
Three different agendas that operate
in the international space
that we're all trying to bind
together in these initiatives.
So how we're trying to do this
is that we are doing modeling
of people and population
modeling and migration modeling
of how people are foreseen to be moving
the future based on different
data sets, crop yield,
water availability, migration patterns,
other things that are have to
do with with climate change
and how this gonna affect people.
I'm not gonna go into RCPs, SSPs,
there's beautiful information
online and Sarah might mention
a little bit about that.
But they're basically
how you set up these different
scenarios for the future
in terms of development and
also in terms of emissions.
And, yeah, we do this up until 2050
to get a pretty good picture down
to really granular information
on how that will look
in the different regions after 2050.
We also couple this with
looking at, here it comes again,
hotspots, we'll go into this hotspots
to conduct qualitative
research through partners
and people in our network.
So we're looking at, for
example, here are the regions
in Africa that we have
gone to and done this.
You'll see Lagos, you see
Guana, you see Beira, et cetera,
where we have done focus
groups and interviews
to get a better understanding
of what's behind these numbers
that we see in the modeling work.
So both seeing what's happening right now
but also seeing people's
outlooks for the future,
which Sarah will talk more about.
Then this leads to consultations.
So we conducted a
consultation process in Africa
and we will do one
degree Caribbean as well.
The one in Africa had over
700 entities participating
in different formats.
Everything from community
members, academia,
policy makers, NGOs.
I think we even had private
sector in some of them.
So we covered quite a lot of
stakeholder groups in there.
So these also leads to the
creation of an Agenda for Action
which we'll get back to,
but it basically is this bridge
between the modeling data,
the information from the qualitative work
and how we can analyze that
and turn it into something
that's actionable.
We also have stakeholder forums
and engage with different constituencies.
I, as you heard in the introduction,
work particularly with youth.
And there we have, especially since
that's the most advanced
advanced initiative,
a very vibrant African youth network
that is working across different
parts of our initiatives.
But I would definitely like to mention
that they for COP last year developed
the Africa Climate
Mobility Youth Declaration
with the African Union Youth
Envoy and various youth groups
that they presented
and they're trying to find different ways
to how to take our data and our research
and bring it out into what's actionable
from a youth perspective.
So looking at the
modeling and the research
and the consultations, what that leads to.
Sarah was one of the lead authors,
so she's gonna talk more
about how this was done,
but it led to the African Shifts report
and the Agenda for Action.
The report is online.
There's a link there you can find after.
Sarah will also go through the details.
I'll not speak a lot about it,
but that is basically taking
all that information together
and putting out in a format
that hopefully is digestible
and not your usual UN report.
And also the Agenda for
Action that are the actions
that we're looking to
hopefully drive up until 2030.
And here for Africa I should
say that this is something
that's done for all the regions,
but this might look different
for the Greater Caribbean.
For Africa this was the
agenda that was advanced
or put forward in this context,
is focused on our plan,
empower and transform and we
have eight different actions
that touches upon different parts
of what we think needs to be done
or not what we think needs to be done,
but people in this
consultations came forward with
as actionable things that we
need to see leading up to 2030
when it comes to climate
mobility in Africa.
Also want to mention this,
we tried to put all this information
on a digital platform as well.
We not only is try, we actually did it
and it is a more digestible
way to communicate the stories
and storytelling is an important
part on how to address this
and make this comprehensible,
'cause there is modeling
going up until 2050
but that's not always
easy to for to understand
what that means for people.
So we have interviews, we have videos,
we have different
stories, we have the data.
The data is available there.
You can go on and play with it yourself,
the different data sets
and see how Africa will
be affected according
to the modeling.
Everything is available
online and you can go
and check it out there.
I wanna wrap up my part here
by talking a little bit about
how we bring this ecosystem together
and how we're trying to
advance the coalitions.
So this is from COP last year where we had
the first climate mobility
pavilion trying to bring
the climate mobility
discussion into the COP space,
which has not been done before.
I don't wanna discredit,
there are certain actors
that of course have operated
in the climate conference space
but it's not been a dedicated pavilion.
So trying to bring the ecosystem together,
we put this pavilion together
and had over 70 events
over 10 days with everything
from heads of states
to communicate activists
participating in coming together.
Also last week as Tony mentioned,
we had the chance to meet Tony
and Tony was one-on-one of the panels.
We had a climate mobility
summit on the margins
of the UN general assembly
bringing together same sort
of variation of stakeholders.
You see Mayor Yvonne from Sierra Leon.
From Freetown, you see
the president of Guatemala
in the middle.
You see the head of the
Association for Caribbean States,
Rodolfo Banque, standing
in the middle as well,
as well as various just UN entities
and academic as well
from another institution.
We don't have to talk
about which institution
but he's hiding up in the corner,
hopefully at Yale next time.
(Sarah chuckles)
- And with that we are
moving into the work
that we've done in Africa.
Maybe just to dovetail
with the where David ended
and kind of, you know,
connect the dots a little bit.
So this initiative has ambitions really
on three different levels.
We started at the regional
level but we're working
across different regions
to connect efforts
at the global level and at
the same time as I'll discuss
a little further going down
from the regional level
down to the national
and community level.
So we are trying to really connect efforts
across these different
levels of governance
and as David already described,
also working across different
sectors of policymaking
as well as across different stakeholders.
So it's really kind of a
pretty intricate puzzle
that we're trying to solve
and it's I think on the one
hand driven by the urgency
of the climate crisis as Tony mentioned.
But I think it's also really
driven by our analysis
of the current geopolitical environment
and the need to elevate the
voices of the global majority
in what is the climate conversation.
So as David mentioned, we
have a discourse on climate
that's driven by mitigation
and decarbonization,
which is important but
for the majority of people
in the world that are most
affected by the climate crisis,
there's very little to
decarbonize in their lives.
And so how do we elevate their concerns
in the global conversation?
That is very much what
drives kind of our work.
For the Africa climate ability,
I actually don't have a
clicker so I'll have to ask you
to click forward, I'll go
a bit through our findings.
David has explained the process.
So we did modeling, we did field research,
we did consultations, we
put together a report.
These are some of our findings
and I'll walk you walk you
through the substance now
and then we'll come back to more
of the process conversation.
This is not our finding,
this is from the IPCC,
but I think it's fairly common knowledge.
We have this discrepancy
between Africa's greenhouse gas emissions,
what I just mentioned.
There are very few countries
that have, you know,
significant work to do on
decarbonization in Africa.
But when we look at the climate risk,
it's very high for much of the continent.
So you have very little
contribution to the problem,
but very high exposure to and
vulnerability to the problem.
We also looked at, and this
is thanks to research done
by our colleague Dr. Nick
Simpson who was a co-author
of the report.
We also looked at what is the level
of climate change literacy
across the continent.
And this is based on Afrobarometer data
and they have looked at
the subnational level,
different districts what's the level
of climate change literacy and
found very high discrepancies
within countries and across countries.
And I think it dovetails
with some of the findings
that you presented Tony last week,
which is that you still
have quite low levels
of climate change knowledge in
many parts of the continent.
Generally the awareness is
higher in cities and urban areas.
It's lower in rural areas
and more remote kind of border regions.
But that doesn't
necessarily always dovetail
with people's lived
experiences as we'll see
from our own field research.
But basically if we are
just going with the kind of,
have people heard of climate change,
do they know what the impacts
might be on their livelihoods,
the rates are quite low,
especially in some of the
most vulnerable areas.
So this is based on the both quantitative
and qualitative data collection.
So we did surveys but also
interviews and this was done
by the mixed migration center for us.
In those seven locations,
David showed a map
with seven locations across the continent.
This is where this was done.
We had a mix of rural and urban areas,
coastal, different types
of climate, impacts
that were already occurring,
some areas affected by drought,
others experiencing
cyclones, sea level rise,
different types of climate impacts.
And what we found across
those seven locations
was that overall the majority
of people very much
notice climate disruptions
in their lives.
Like they're aware that this is happening
but it's not something that they consider
or most of them do not consider to move
because of those disruptions.
So for a majority more than
50% they say, "Yeah, you know,
we see stuff is happening,
we take certain measures to try to adapt,
but moving is not necessarily
one that we would wanna take
or are considering taking."
You have almost a quarter
though that say, "Yeah,
we would maybe move if we
had the resources to do so."
So the constraint on
moving has often has to do
with the resources that
people have available
or their own perception
of those resources.
If we look at reasons
for moving, you can see,
and this is not surprising
I think from the literature,
but it confirms a lot of existing research
that very much climate change
interacts with other factors
that make people want to
move, consider moving.
And here we looked at economic impacts.
So livelihood factors most of the time,
and you see that in most of
the cases it's more livelihood
or income related reasons
that would make people consider
moving or want to move.
The outliers are really in areas
where you had fairly recent
extreme events like Beira,
for example, which was hit by cyclone
and I think it's covered here,
but had a very fairly high
percentage of people saying,
"Yes, we wanna move."
Similarly, Chihuahua in Malawi,
which was like hit by
different impacts alternating
between flooding and drought.
And so where people
were kind of at a point
where they were like, "Okay,
we are ready to move because of this
because it's just been too much whiplash."
But generally, for example,
in a Lagos or Alexandria where
people had some perception
of climate impacts,
it was mostly about
like living conditions,
how can we move to a better neighborhood?
But it was less driven
by the climate factor.
This is the gender breakdown.
And what we found across locations,
it's not always true,
but mostly women were more
reluctant to move than men.
So they had less intentions to move.
And if you go to the next
slide, this is by age group,
we found that the young
people were those most prone
to wanting to move.
So the majority of
young people still said,
"I'm not considering moving,"
but they were the largest age
group that had actually plans
to move were more actively
engaged in making those plans.
Next slide.
So then we go to the quantitative work,
and this is based on the modeling
that David briefly presented.
We did two types of modeling.
We looked at cross-border migration
and we looked at internal movements
and we did not manage to do
both within the same model.
So we had two separate models.
This is the findings for
the cross-border movement.
And this was a pilot I would say.
So the methodology was quite new
and the results are I
think fairly significant.
But also, you know, in the context
of the overall population development
in Africa, not overwhelming.
So you have a fairly small percentage
of overall projected
movement being related
to climate change, right?
Like this is the total projection
of cross border migrants
that could be moving by 2050.
And then within that the
climate related movement
is a fairly small percentage
and, sorry, this is the
more optimistic scenario
in terms of climate impacts
and this is the more pessimistic scenario,
so you'll also see that actually
the impact of climate change
have a more reducing impact
on cross border mobility,
which makes sense again if we
look at the need for people
to have resources to move.
Next slide.
Then we have internal movements,
so people moving within countries
and that is a more significant
amount of people projected
to be moving anywhere
between 46 to 113 million.
So if we stay within the
scenarios, the most likely outcome
under a kind of high emissions future
is around 88 million people,
4% of the African population
moving within their countries.
But it could go up to 113.
A more optimistic scenario
when it comes to development
in climate emissions sees
a lower range of internal mobility.
And this is the hotspots analysis.
So one thing is to try to
put numbers on the movement.
I think the more important maybe potential
of this analysis lies with understanding
the geographic distribution
of why are those movements
likely to happen?
So what this map shows are areas
that are likely to be origins
or destinations respectively of movements.
And you see that they're
quite concentrated
in the Sahel belt on the coasts
and then also on some
of the border regions
like Lake Victoria, for example,
you have the border region
between Ethiopia, Sudan, Eritrea.
So this is what we'll be
using going forward working
with governments at the
more national, sub-regional
and local level is hotspots analysis.
So this is the next step after we've done
the continental level analysis
and had kind of have presented our results
and Agenda for Action,
we are now working with
individual countries,
sub-regional organizations and cities
to take these hotspots
analysis down to the country,
local sub-regional level to
help them start making sense
of prospective population
shifts within their territory
and how our analysis
cross references with data
that they may be having at
the local and national level.
So we're trying to integrate
different sources of data
and knowledge at the national level,
at the local level with a
view to supporting planning,
policy development at
that level of intervention
and eventually drive towards
projects and programming
in those hotspots areas.
So the first country where
we're doing this is Uganda.
This is the steps of the
process and it mirrors very much
the kind of process we've gone through
at the regional level.
So we start with this
analysis of different data
and research, bringing
together our modeling data
with other sources of
data and information.
We go through a phase of consultations now
within the country and
then want to develop
what we call a blueprint.
This could, I think,
take different forms depending
on the country context,
but the ultimate goal is to
influence both adaptation
and development planning that's happening
at the country level
with this information about
like where are the areas,
the geographies, but
also the groups of people
and the sectors of your economy
that you should be
particularly concerned about
when it comes to people moving.
This is from the climate mobility profile
we have pulled together for Uganda,
starting with climate information,
what are the trends in the country?
Next slide, what are the hazards
and how are people affected by them?
So for Uganda you see
different types of hazards,
you don't see this here,
but they're affecting
different parts of the country.
Next slide.
Then again we are looking
at the climate literacy rates based
on the data we used also for
the continental level analysis,
so understanding different
levels of climate literacy
across the country and then
we're drawing on our own data
to look at what's the
situation for Uganda?
So how will cross border
flows for Uganda look like
over the next 30 years?
Here you can see.
But much more movement projected
to go out of the country
than coming into the country.
Next slide.
Internal projections.
This is what we saw
for the continental level.
Here in Uganda,
the high point is 5.1
million potential internally,
displaced people or people moving.
And this is the hotspots map for Uganda.
One is the kind of most likely
where different scenarios
of the modeling have the
highest level of agreement.
This is how you get to this map.
And this map is the actual
numbers of people projected
to move from one part of the country
to another part of the country.
And those pixels are roughly four
to five square kilometers.
So that's the resolution.
Then we look at what are existing factors
of vulnerability such as
the climate literacy rates,
but also where are, for
example, existing refugee camps
or refugee populations?
So looking at them as a group of concern
but also looking at things
like poverty levels and marginalization.
Next slide.
And this is our analysis by cities.
So we have different ways
of looking at the data.
For the continental level,
we did a geographic regions analysis,
we looked at urban areas,
we looked at rural areas,
coastal areas separately.
And we're doing the same
at the country level.
So this is the city level analysis,
which are the cities that will be growing
because there's overall urbanization
and population growth going on,
but where climate mobility
could be leading to a dent
in that growth.
So basically you have
cities that are growing
but because of climate impacts,
there are some people forecast
predicted to leave that city,
which kind of suggests
that overall conditions
in the city could become more
hazardous also for people
who are not leaving.
And then you have cities
that are projected
to grow due to climate mobility.
So where climate mobility
is actually contributing meaningfully
to the growth of the city.
And you see kind of like this
flip side here in Uganda.
Next slide.
So what are we doing
next with this analysis?
We're planning to have consultations,
engagement with
stakeholders across Uganda.
So going to different parts of the country
to share our initial findings,
but to understand what
are the local realities
and how does this inter
intersect with what's going on?
How people are perceiving climate impacts
and the movement of
people, the implications
that already resolved at the moment
with a view to co-developing
recommendations for action,
looking at what could
be pilot interventions
in areas that are particularly impacted,
and then also seeing at
how do we get to a level
of granularity that could
actually support decision making
like if you wanted to decide
to put water infrastructure
in a certain place or
to build more housing
in a certain place, the modeling
that we have is not sufficiently detailed
and you see it has these
large uncertainty intervals.
So, you know, we wouldn't be like, "Yeah,
you should really put your housing here
because our model says you know this."
So the idea is also like
how do we start based on
more locally collected data
to build decision support tools,
which would be more agent-based models?
So like actually understanding
what are the local dynamics
and how do we develop support tools
that can actually inform these kinds
of infrastructure investment decisions,
policy making at a more
local and granular level?
Yep.
I know we kind of like
take a step back up.
So in Africa we've kind of gone
from the continental down
to the country and local.
In the Greater Caribbean,
we are starting where we
started in Africa two years ago
with an effort at kind
of mobilizing interest
and political buy-in for the initiative,
which was officially launched last year.
So we've been holding a number of events,
just socializing this
idea and this initiative
with governments in the region.
We have started modeling and we're using
a different approach this time.
So the model that we
use for Africa is called
a gravity model.
It's based mainly focused
on kind of geographic assumptions about
how people are distributed in space
and then when climate impacts
kind of are layered in,
how does that affect the attractiveness
of places vis-a-vis each other?
This is an econometric model
we are using this time.
So it looks much more
at how climate impacts will
affect different sectors
of the economy and labor
productivity, and different sectors
of the economy, and how that
will affect people's decisions
to go to certain areas or
move out of other areas.
So we're expecting to have quite
different types of results.
It will still give us an idea of again,
like what are hotspots areas,
but it will be much more tied
to what is the economic impact
of climate change
and how is this affecting
people's decisions to move?
And this is our roadmap.
We're working towards COP 29,
so that means end of 2024
to basically arrive at what David laid out
the process of first doing the research,
then doing the consultations,
having a report,
having stories, bringing it all to COP
and then again like in
that region as well,
starting to work with
individual champion countries
to look at what does this mean for you?
How do we bring this
down to the local level
while at the same time
continuing to build that momentum
in global policy forum.
So that was a lot. (chuckles)
Now the floor is yours.
- Great.
(crowd claps)
Questions, comments
also, (chuckles) funny.
- [Crowd Member] Thank you so much
for this great presentation.
I just have a quick question
going back to your point
on using different models
for different regions,
would you mind explaining
a little bit more
of why you decide your team decided to use
the gravity based model for Africa
and then the more sectorial
economic-based approach
for campaigns and maybe maybe
different kinds of models
you use for other regions
do your project cover?
- Yeah, should I go ahead?
The main reason was that for
the gravity model to work well,
you basically need some territory
to move people around on
(chuckles) and with a
lot of the small islands
in the Caribbean, it's very difficult.
Like the model is struggling
to basically project movements
if the territory is very small.
And so I think the search
for a different alternative model led us
to this econometric model.
We had a workshop with all kinds
of different modelers
presenting different approaches
that they're currently pursuing.
What we are looking for I think is always
an approach that is globally applicable,
which limits options.
So we are trying to find
models that can work
across different regions ultimately.
So we I think are looking, yeah,
to as much as possible get
inputs in terms of the data
that are region specific,
but have a model that can be applied
across different contexts.
Yeah, but the main reason
was that we were trying to look
at these small island states
and the gravity model at
according to our colleagues
who are doing the modeling is not so good
at looking at population redistribution
in these very small territories.
- Could you speak
a little bit more about
the decision support tools
that sort of are a need
now and how they interplay
with the current models that you have
and like what you would
hope that they would answer?
- Yeah, so I think again,
like our model gives kind
of an indication of, okay,
these are areas that you
should be concerned about
or look at for action. (chuckles)
But then when it comes to
actually guiding decisions
on, you know, again putting in
place specific infrastructure
or maybe expanding social
protection programs
or what have you,
like actually kind of a
better understanding of, well,
how many people when are
they going to move based
on which triggers or thresholds?
You need something that is more informed
by what's actually really
going on in the country.
Because what we know is that the model
that we have is informed
by global climate models
that often struggle to represent
what's happening in Africa
because there's not so
much data collection
and data available.
So you have often
assumptions being made also
on the migration side about
like, well, let's, you know,
use Ghana and expand the data from Ghana
across these other five countries
for which we don't have
data, that kind of thing.
Which then if you are actually
in one of those other five
countries is not so helpful,
right, your model is
not informed by the data
that actually is reflecting
the local reality.
And so if you want something
that can actually support
decisions on like should we build
a sea wall here, or put water pipes there,
or build housing here, you need something
that reflects more like
actual dynamics in the country
and you have companies and consultancies
that do that kind of work.
So we are trying to see, you know,
once we have our more broader
analysis of like, okay,
you know, we know
that these coastal areas you
should be concerned about,
how do we bring that expertise
to our government partners
to then say, okay, let's do
the more granular analysis
of, you know,
you might wanna put this piece
of infrastructure in this way
or, yeah, so to actually
kind of like get started
on specific projects.
Yep.
- Yeah, so thank you both so much.
Aside from the suggestions or the action
that the results of these models
might, you know, point out
for the countries that
will experience, you know,
the harshest effects
of the climate crisis,
I guess what have you found
in terms of showing this data
to the countries that
are the biggest causes
and how do you feel as
if this kind of a finding
or these kinds of reports are
moving the needle politically
or is it just another drop in the ocean?
- That's a good question.
I mean, I think the main
concern usually for countries
in the global north,
if you will is is more around
like who's coming to us,
right, like do you have
figures for Africans moving
to Europe or Latin
Americans moving to the US?
I think what we are trying
to convey is the message
that, you know, most people
are moving close to home,
which is already true,
but will most likely be
true in the future too
from what we know and what we observe.
So, yes, there will be
also south north movements,
but the majority of movement
is happening close to home
and people are not all, you
know, clamoring to leave.
And so really what we're trying
to, I think pinpoint is A
the need for scaling up
adaptation investment,
which is not a new message,
but to reinforce that point
but then also to guide
that investment, right?
Like to say if you are trying to, again,
in a more anticipatory fashion,
not just kind of try to
get on top of disasters
and do recovery on a perpetual basis,
but to try to look ahead
and see how can we get ahead of the curve
in certain instances and say, "Okay,
this is where people are likely to move
if we can put investment
here now, you know,
then the city does not
have to become overwhelmed
with informal settlements
where living conditions are terrible.
You can start putting
infrastructure in place now,"
you can start, you know,
thinking about economic sectors
where people could find jobs now.
So that is a little bit the logic
on what we're hoping to
achieve is basically,
A, get to a clear message
around like, you know,
get out of your navel gazing
(chuckles) if you will.
You know, the problems are acute
and they're for people already real now
and then, you know, start planning ahead
and supporting countries
before the situation becomes a crisis.
- Could you say a bit more,
I'm just thinking back in
the Africa model and the maps
that you had of the places
where people would be be fleeing from
and where they would be going to,
so the red versus the green locations,
what variables are associated
or seem to be predictive
of either of those two locations
where people would be
moving from or moving to?
- Yeah, so the model generally assumes
that people will be drawn to
more densely populated areas.
So it has kind of like a
bias towards urbanization,
assuming that people will wanna be
where there's more amenities
and that those places are more attractive.
But then basically what it does
is like it looks at a future
where you have just development happening
and where would people be
in terms of population distribution.
And then it compares that to a scenario
where you have climate impacts happening
and the climate impacts
are on water availability,
on crop productivity, and are
on rangeland productivity.
So to cover kind of grazing
livestock-based livelihoods.
And those are the main kind
of factors that influence
the attractiveness of
places in the future.
So you'll see basically the
model moving people out of areas
that where water availability
goes down and into areas
where water availability goes up.
We've tried to capture things
like conflict in the model,
but it's very imperfect
at this stage in the sense
that you cannot predict
conflict into the future.
So you kind of have to
assume like certain areas
that had conflict in the
past will be less attractive
because of conflict in the future,
but we know that that's
not really how it works,
where like the conflict may
be moving somewhere else.
So that's a limitation.
And I think it does
account to a certain extent
for existing mobility patterns,
but it obviously it cannot
capture all the intricacies
of like family ties and ethnic ties
and, you know, like that drive
a lot of people's decisions
for where they're gonna go.
- [Crowd Member] So
there's actually current,
contemporary data on
how people already move
within some of these
locations that you can draw on
as an input into the model.
- Well, the problem is that
I think you could do that
for these more smaller
scale agent based models.
So if you wanted to actually
really say like, okay,
we're in Accra, Ghana
and we wanna understand
how might people be moving into Accra?
I think you could start
like really looking at
what are the existing migration patterns
and how do we build a model based on that.
But for these kind of like
models that are trying to do this
at scale, I mean, you don't
have that data at scale, right?
So that's the incompatibility if you will,
like that you need data that is available
across different locations
to have these kind of global models
or whole of continent models.
- But as also I think it's important
to have the different
stages of the research
as well with the modeling.
That takes it down to the
other parts as well with both
the qualitative part and the consultation,
but also then, yeah, why it's important.
you might say then like,
"You've done the work,
why you go to the national
level, local level?"
Of course that sounds like,
but it is really important
to understand the real drivers of this,
to talk to those people.
I think that that's the
experience as well to really get
a sense of, yeah, a
decision to move is not easy
and it's usually not as
you cannot summarize it
as is one point driving it,
it's usually more complex
and few points going into it.
- [Crowd Member] So thank
you for this presentation.
And I have also like a question
related to the assumptions
that you have.
So every model, the
result of a model depends
on the assumption that you're taking.
So if you can tell us
a little bit more about
how you are gathering that information
and what challenges you
have encountered as well
in order to building that
and how to calibrate
basically also with things
that you see in the future.
And the other question that I have
is that, so you have these
ranges of probabilities
of the forecast that the results
that you can see, are you
building with that as well,
like different scenarios depending
on how extreme you can
see or certain parameters
that go after some
level as well, you know,
to have the know the
recommendation or the work
that you are gonna be working
with the different government?
- I'm not sure I understood
the second part of your question.
On the first part, so we
didn't build the model.
We work with colleagues
who are on the one hand
at City University of New
York and Columbia University
and they built this model originally
for the World Bank's Groundswell reports
and then upgraded it for our purposes.
So we built in,
they used different population
data for this model.
They used more layers
of climate information.
So they put in a flood mask for example.
They added this conflict mask.
So there were more factors layered in
than that was the case
for the Groundswell model.
And the calibration as far as I know,
was done basically picking again,
countries for which data
is available and looking at
in the past how have
certain things like drought
or flooding affected migration
and use that to kind
of predict the future.
So, yeah, there's lots of kind of things
where, you know, you say
okay, again, you know,
what we find for Cameroon and Ghana
and five other countries
we're gonna now use
across other countries, right?
Where you can always say,
"Well, how accurate is that
as an assumption to be made?"
On the second part.
Yeah.
- [Crowd Member] So on the
second part what I was saying
is that, so you have a path
of the more likely scenario,
but you also are showing the
results like a probability
of this event happening.
So what I'm saying is that given
that more extremes event
are happening more often,
are you able as well to build
like different scenarios?
Okay, I don't know if
temperature rises by this much,
which I dunno exactly from five
or whatever figure you
you want to put there,
this is more likely to be the effect.
So you will be more like on
the tails of the distribution
and basically, as I said,
work with the government
in terms of well trying to
adapt to the different events.
- Yeah, yeah.
So we for this exercise that
for scenarios and actually
in the report we mainly focused
on the kind of pessimistic
scenario in the sense
that the optimistic
scenario was really we stay
within 1.5, you know, we are
meeting the Paris targets
and we said that is not the
most likely outcome, right?
So we actually have mostly
in the report focused on the
more pessimistic scenario,
but then said, "You know,
even with the more kind of
negative climate trajectory,
you can see that the development
trajectory matters, right?"
Like, because there's
basically these two variables.
How are you doing on development
and how are you doing on climate?
And even if climate is not going well,
if the emissions reductions
are not happening fast,
whether you make progress
on development makes
a big difference in terms
of the vulnerability
of your population.
And so that's been the main message
for African governments
basically from the report
to say like, "You know, you
can not do so much about
the emissions reductions,
there's not so much in your power.
I mean, you can obviously
advocate and so on,
but at the end of the day
there's not so much again
to decarbonize in a lot
of these countries,"
but you can do quite a lot
about the development, well,
quite a lot you can do something about
the development trajectory
and that's where the kind
of difference can be made
in terms of outcomes.
- [Crowd Member] So just
to follow up on that,
so I mean I think you said
that "Under the rocky road scenario,
which is the worst case scenario,
migration actually is slightly lower
than in a more optimistic scenario,"
which is an eye-opening point.
And I think you said
"It's because that people
won't even have the resources
that they need in order to migrate,
which means they're trapped,
which means things are
much worse in location
where people aren't, right,
interpreting that right?
- Yeah.
And I think from this Caribbean model,
this comes out even more starkly
that you'll basically just
have a share of the population
that's gonna be very poor,
not very likely to be moving,
especially not across
international borders.
And that's maybe the people
that you should be most concerned about.
But, yeah, I mean we've found that,
and again, this is our interpretation,
but I think it is consistent also
with some of the, you know,
field research findings
and what we know from the
existing migration research
that especially going longer distance,
international is expensive.
You need contacts, you need money.
And so if people are moving,
they're moving short distances.
If they don't have those
contacts and those resources,
they're not moving across the continent,
let alone to like Europe or anywhere.
- [Crowd Member] There is
a question on the chat.
So Elisa is asking, first
she wants to thank you
for the very interesting presentation
and she would like to inquire
if you also provide support
to policy makers regarding
the social economic and cultural
integration of migrants.
And does your organization
offer data about the regions
and condition of origin while also working
to raise awareness within
the host community?
Additionally, do you
suggest best practices
for social inclusion?
- (laughs) Hopefully at some point.
I know, I mean, so I think
the interesting piece
about this hotspots mapping
is that it gives you
both end of the story.
It doesn't allow you actually
to make connections between places.
So you can't really say,
"Okay, these people are coming
from here and they're going to there.
It can only tell you, well,
here's where we think
population will decline
and here's where we
think it will increase.
But I do think that this analysis
of where population will increase
is very interesting and valuable.
And I've come from quite a
bit of work with the city
and local authorities and
so I think we do see that
as a very important
constituency of our effort.
So looking at, you know, A,
what do they already know?
Because there's been a
lot of lessons learned
from large scale displacement crisis,
whether they're climate
related or not, like Lima,
Peru taking in a million
Venezuelans, you know,
so there is a lot of, I think,
things that cities have
already done and know how to do
and it's not always well publicized.
But then also, yes, we do,
I think ultimately would
like to get to a point
where through this knowledge hub,
we start collecting more information
on the solutions, right?
Like so far
a lot of the climate mobility
research has been focused
on the drivers like understanding
how important is climate as a
driver of people's movement?
Where will people leave,
where will they go?
I think increasingly you wanna shift
the research agenda also
towards this question of, well,
what can be done in response
and what do we know about
things that are working?
- And I think that that also covers a part
that was not really part
of this presentation,
which comes to our flagship programs
that hopefully is gonna
address some part of that,
that's gonna focus on green
skills, climate literacy,
water solution, and data.
So of course it ties into the research
that's presented here, but I
think that there's ambition
and there's also interest
and also already some efforts going on
through these programs that's
gonna address hopefully both
the host communities and people
staying, as Tony mentioned,
people being trapped or not
having the opportunity to decide
where they're gonna move.
So hopefully those parts
will cover social inclusion
to some degree, 'cause I know
that was part of the question,
but definitely the economic part
when it comes to green skills.
- [Sarah] Yeah.
- So we've reached five o'clock, so.
- I have that.
Yeah, I think we have 15 minutes more,
but, and I have one question
and then other people
if they want.
So what, yeah, I would like to know
as well how much you include
the risk into your model
and basically what I'm thinking
is about people insurance
against these events.
I understand that probably
in developing countries
and not everybody is able to
ensure against climate change,
but I guess working with
the governments actually
in order to sort of
incorporate the risk of living
in these areas that you have identified
as we move from to to
these, yeah, problems.
- Yeah, I think this goes
a bit to what we discussed,
like how do we get them to
more kind of decision support.
I mean, I do think we know
that social protection,
for example, can be
both a means for people
to stay in places, but
it can also be a means
for people to move, right,
depending on the context.
So I think in terms of what
is a appropriate response,
I guess we want to make
sure that people have agency
in a certain degree of wellbeing,
whether they stay or move, right?
So the intervention I think
whether it's risk insurance
or it's social protection,
I think if we are kind of
trying to measure success
by whether we manage to make people stay
or have them move might be tricky.
And I think that's another question
that is kind of on the
table as we are advocating
for climate mobility to become part
of adaptation programming,
adaptation policy,
how do we measure success?
What does that look like?
But yeah, to your point,
I think it's definitely one
of our action agenda items
is around this like, you know,
how do you just basically ensure
that people can make
decisions about moving
with, A, having information
about climate risks.
So this goes to climate literacy,
but also access to climate services,
but also how do they have
kind of the resources
that they would need to be able
to make those decisions, so,
and then in a lot of cases that
will mean social protection
or access to climate risk insurance,
like things that will
actually allow them to have
a certain degree of agency
in the context of disasters
and climate impacts.
- And I think that that
covers some part of it,
the social part and economic part,
but I think they're also the
part what culture and heritage
that we also try to cover,
but that is not covered
by those factors, yeah,
for certain communities
that's something that I
just wanna put opinion
that we are trying to address as well.
That in always your question, Theresa,
but I think that that goes
beyond this question was asked online
and this like, it's not only
the social and the economic,
but also the culture and
heritage of community
and the community.
Yeah.
Hopefully it comes that in
the third phase of things
to really see what we can
do for communities there.
- Gentleman there.
- [Crowd Member] Thank you so much.
This is so interesting
and so many questions,
but I want to start with one
and could you clarify please,
when you speak about zones,
where people tend to migrate,
like green zones mostly,
are those better off
somehow in any parameters,
as a result of climate change
or they're just less worse off?
And are there any areas
which are better off somehow,
physically, environmentally
as a result of climate
change in the continent
or maybe economically
because of the migration
and labor somehow
or the whole continent it would be divorce
or just a different base?
- That's a really good question.
I think you have both.
So you have actually situations
where people are basically just
going from one bad situation
to maybe a less bad situation.
So, for example, if the results
for Mozambique show quite
a lot of movement into the coastal areas
that are we know very vulnerable,
but because the conditions
in the rural hinterlands
are predicted to get worse,
and so the model is
moving people to the coast
where you have bigger cities,
but that doesn't mean they're
out of a risky environment.
But then you also have I think,
certain areas of the continent
that could actually
see conditions improve,
like where crop yields are forecast
to improve due to more rainfall.
So you have a little bit of both,
but I would say very often,
especially this movement into
urban areas is not necessarily
a movement into much better conditions,
especially if urbanization
isn't handled well, right?
And that goes to your point
around like economic opportunity.
I think a lot depends on, again,
like forward planning
and investment, right,
to see how can that be absorbed?
Like we know people will
be moving into this areas,
can you already put
infrastructure in place now
that will make it easier afterwards
to build up housing, for example,
if you already have the basic
infrastructure in place,
then it's easier
rather than trying to
retrofit informal settlements
that have already sprung up.
Things like that.
But, yeah, it's not
necessarily a rosy pick, right?
Like there's many places
where you're like, "Oh,
these will be climate havens." (chuckles)
Yeah.
- And I think you shouldn't, yeah,
not be fooled by colors of green and red.
It doesn't mean that it's
green, it's green light or red.
It's very simplistic to say,
but it doesn't cover
that part I think, no?
- Yeah.
- [Crowd Member] Just one quick question.
I know we're running against time,
but I'm curious around your strategies
around kind of evidence uptake
and sort of sensitization
localization of these tools
and this information.
Obviously it'll be as
good as whoever uses it
for some of the planning
and decision making,
and it strikes me as it's potentially
a wide array of different policy makers
who could avail themselves
of this information.
So, you know, I'm curious
how you're working
in collaboration with
national subnational actors
to kind of promote uptake
of this information
and to promote uptake of the
tools that will be developed.
- Yeah, so I think right now,
and David can speak to that more,
but I think we see it mainly
as an awareness raising tool
and also as a tool, again,
to inform this kind of global level,
more advocacy conversations,
bringing people together,
starting this conversation,
putting the topic on the agenda.
When it comes to the
more policy formulation,
then it really becomes
this work that I outlined
with like Uganda, where it's like, "Okay,
let's work with this government.
Let's see, you know, how
concretely can we help you
to make this part of your
planning, like this part
of your policies, and
how ultimately, you know,
where we wanna get to is
help Uganda unlock money
from the Green Climate Fund
to have specific projects
in place, that's where
we would like to get to
with these countries."
And so I think we have kind of
probably different strategies
with different audiences
and also still working on
our strategies. (chuckles)
So that's also true.
But, yeah.
- No, I think, yeah, I
think you covered it, Sarah.
I think it's also part of then, yeah,
the climate literacy part that
caused by climate literacy.
But then we also have the
climate mobility literacy part,
which is, yeah, you can
see the numbers there
on climate literacy.
I don't think we're close to
that on the climate mobility,
trying to merge these agendas
and have a conversation about it here.
I don't think that's a necessarily
a conversation in the US
or in Europe where I'm from,
but less so there even.
So I think that that's both
on the national, sub-regional,
but also on the, yeah, looking at COP,
we talked about COP before.
I think it's starting to
make its way in there.
We said we did a pavilion.
It doesn't mean that it's
front and center negotiations,
but there are different things
we're trying to do there
to bring it up.
Then, yeah, we can talk more about,
we're trying to do these
flagship programs as well.
And also working with youths to see like,
what does this information mean for to you
and what would it be helpful
to take it and do it?
And I think that that's
something that, especially youth
that I work with are kind
of keen to figure out
with their peers in terms
of, right, now we know this,
how do we go and take action on this.
Of course, there's more formal
process with governments
that we're working at the national level,
but are also these
constituency-based as you mentioned,
yeah, other types of organizations.
There are a lot of youth
that have a lot of interest
in seeing this is happening
a lot in their communities.
- I think that where this idea
of ecosystem building comes in, I mean,
just looking at the
conversation here in the US
and how that's evolving
around like, you know,
climate displacement, climate refugees,
I think you'll in each
context need kind of people
that figure out
what the narrative needs
to look like locally.
Because I think in most contexts, it's not
an easy conversation, right,
to talk to people about
where they might have
to abandon their homes.
And we've heard quite a few stories
of people going back to places
that they were relocated from, right?
Like where the government said, "Okay,
Beira is one example."
We heard the same in Uganda,
where like the government said,
"Okay, you have keep having landslides,
we gotta move you out of this area."
But this area is very fertile for farming.
So people will be coming back there.
In Beira, they come back
because they do fishing, right?
And if you relocate them to the interior,
that's just not where their livelihood is.
So I think in practice a lot
of these things are hard to do
and governments are often not
super keen to take this on
as a conversation with their people.
And so I think that's something
where I think we can
give governments tools,
but to figure out like,
how do we talk about this
in a way that resonates
with our community in a way
that resonates with our people,
I think that's the work
that they will have to do.
And where we will also learn, right,
what does that look like?
- And I think that
that's also a little bit
what led us here,
'cause we talked to Tony last
year trying to figure out
how to talk about these things.
(Sarah chuckles)
So I think that, yeah,
there are people here that
are trying to figure it out
for the US and we're we're
determined to figure it out
to some degree across the world
when it comes to climate mobility.
- I think we are working more hands on.
David mentioned the
Rising Nations Initiative,
which is also a regional effort,
but it's slightly differently organized.
And there it's a much more hands-on effort
with one particular country,
which is that is facing
submersion this century.
And so there it's much more
hands-on thinking about this.
Like how can the government
go about formulating
a strategy with the people,
like with involvement of the people,
what does that look like?
How do we on the one hand
keep fighting for our right
to adapt and to stay while
also making preparations
for the eventuality that maybe
people will have to move,
and then what David mentioned,
what does that mean for
culture and heritage of people?
How do you preserve that?
What does it mean for their
statehood and their sovereignty?
So that's a kind of like
special project, if you will,
that we are working on.
And that is getting
a little bit more directly
into these kinds of questions.
- Yeah, but tool will be in the pilot.
But now also it is for
Pacific tools in general,
but I think it's kind of clear
also when you start talking
about this Rising Nations Initiative
that a lot of the things are things
that people are thinking
about across the world,
but especially in the
other Pacific countries.
So even though, yeah,
the Rising Nations
initiative is spearheaded
by Tuvalu, Marshall Islands and Kiribati,
as soon as you start talking about it,
there are other Pacific
countries that say, "Oh,
we might not face a merchant,
but these questions of cultural
and heritage applies to us as well."
And I feel like when I talk
to our colleagues in Africa,
that those are also things that
are starting to come up more
and more, so even if it's
not existential threats
to the same degree, there
are questions that remain.
- Yeah, I think the poetical
urgency is different.
Yeah.
- [Crowd Member] Well with
that, thank you very much
and thank you all. (drowned
out by crowd clapping)
(crowd claps)
- Thank you. (chuckles)
(music)